Guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Korkmaz. Ich bin Dienstabender auf dieser Station. Würde ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen? Sind Sie damit ein Verstand?
Ja, ja, klar. Die Hauptsache mir hilft jemand.
Okay, bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre personische Daten aufnehmen. Also wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Richard Huber.
Wie haben Sie Ihre Nachname bestaubieren?
Ja, du hast ganz einfach. H-u-b-e-r.
Okay, Herr Huber. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63.
63. Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 18.07.1960.
Herr Huber, wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß und wiege 94 kg.
94.
Okay, Herr Huber. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, irgendwie habe ich heute etwas Komisches erlebt. Wir müssen dazu sagen, es ist jetzt Vormittags.
Also, ich war heute Morgen verabredet mit meinen Freunden und wir wollten zusammen eine Fahrradtour machen.
Das Wetter war ja nicht so schlecht und dann hatten wir vor, eine schöne Fahrradtour zu machen.
Aber es ist was Dummes passiert, ich bin ein bisschen spät aufgestanden.
Und dann habe ich nicht so gut gefrügstückt wie sonst.
Und ich glaube, das ist mir nicht so gut bekommen.
Ich bin dann mit einem mal beim Fahrradfahren ist mir so schlecht geworden.
Ich konnte gar nicht mehr weiterfahren.
Erstens mal konnte ich nicht mehr gut gucken.
Ich hatte so verschwommenes Bild vor Augen und hatte wirklich das Gefühl, Puh, jetzt muss ich aber mal schauen.
Dann wurde mir mit einmal ganz heiß.
Ich hatte, ich habe geschwitzt und mein Herz hat geklopft.
Und ich war ganz so die Hände haben bisschen gezittert.
Und Puh, da habe ich gemerkt, oh jetzt stimmt aber irgendwas nicht.
Und dann haben die Freunde, die haben dann jemanden angerufen, der mich abgeholt hat mit dem Auto und bekannten mich.
Wir waren zum Glück noch nicht so weit gekommen.
Und die haben sich dann um mein Fahrrad gekümmert und dann bin ich gleich hierher gekommen.
Herr Huber, Sie haben, Sie hatten keine Unfall, aber Sie fühlen sich schlecht.
Und Ihre Gucken sind nicht so gut.
Und Sie haben schwitzt.
Ich kann nicht gut schauen, genau.
Okay.
Und Sie denken, Sie haben morgen nicht gut Frühstück gemacht.
Das war nicht so viel Zeit.
Und dann habe ich nur schnell eine Kleinigkeit gegessen.
Und ja, dann habe ich mit einmal Unterwäsch gemerkt, oh jetzt geht es aber gar nicht mehr weiter.
Moment, dann haben Sie sehr Sturmge.
Jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe dann jetzt Traubenzucker gegessen.
Und seitdem geht es mir ein bisschen besser.
Und wie viele Minuten dauert die sehr Probleme?
Oh, das hat schon eine Weile gedauert.
Also ja, die sind dann alle um mich rumgestanden,
als ich dann mein Fahrrad abgestellt habe und haben beratschlagt, was sie machen sollen.
Und ja, was ist denn los mit dir, Richard?
Und alle waren ganz besorgt um mich.
Und ich habe mich nur schlecht gefühlt, ja.
Aber Sie waren nicht ohne Macht?
Ohne Macht, ich war nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich war nur so komisch zitterig.
Und ja, was ich auch gemerkt habe, dass die Hände so gekribbelt haben.
Okay, beide Hände oder nur eine Hände?
Ne beide.
Beide.
Und leiden Sie unter Kraftlosigkeit oder irgendwelche Extremität?
Hat Parisel vielleicht Lehmung?
Nee, gelehm.
Das Gefühl hatte ich überhaupt nicht.
Nein, nein.
Ich hatte nur so ein allgemeines, schwächer Gefühl.
Und ja, hatte auch eben dieses starke Herz.
Kopf von Augenblick.
Das ist jetzt zum Glück wieder weg.
Hatten Sie Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Okay.
Oder Herzrasen?
Also starke Herzklopfen, das habe ich gemerkt,
dass das Herz mit einmal tüchtig geklopft hat.
Hatten Sie die Herzdruck?
Nein, würde ich nicht sagen.
Okay, sind Sie schwindelig?
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, nicht schwindelig ist mir jetzt nicht.
Nein.
Und da vielleicht war mir so ein bisschen schwindelig,
als ich dann vom Fahrrad abgestiegen bin.
Ja, das war dann auch gleich zu Anfang, ein bisschen anstrengend zu fahren.
Wir sind ja jetzt in der Zeit,
wir fahren immer ganz zügig.
Und da habe ich mich halt am Anfang gleich ein bisschen angestrengt.
Mit einmal ging das nicht mehr.
Herr Huber, jetzt möchte ich unsere Gesprächs unterbrechen.
Und ich messe Ihre Vitalparamete,
Ihre Blutzucker-Messen.
Okay.
Ja, aber ich habe auch die
Blutzucker-Messen.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Und Ihre Blutdruck auch.
Okay, alles in Ordnung.
Okay, ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre aktuelle Zustand,
generelle Zustand stellen.
Fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Nein, fieblich fühle ich mich eigentlich gar nicht.
Wie ist Ihre Appatit?
Normalerweise ist es gut, ja.
Haben Sie in der Lesterzeit ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, das könnte ich mich jetzt nicht.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Ich fiege immer so 94 Kilomal,
ein bisschen mehr mal, ein bisschen weniger, aber so um 94.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stulgern?
Ja, also nachts muss ich schon mal auf die Toilette.
Ja, das glaube ich in meinem Alter nicht so etwas Besonderes.
Ja, aber durch die Schwierigkeiten habe ich da eigentlich nicht.
Okay, könnten Sie ausreichend schlafen?
Ich kann nicht gut schlafen, ja.
Wie viel Kistern brauchen Sie bei schlafen?
Wie viel Kissen?
Ja, dann einen Kopfkissen, einen Kopfkissen habe ich.
Okay, Herr Huber, leiden Sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen
wie Zuckerkrankheit, Polypockdruck?
Ja, ja, ja.
Also die Zuckerkrankheit, das hat man jetzt erst vor,
ja, noch nicht mal im Jahr festgestellt.
Und dann habe ich erst mal eine ganze Weile nur mit Formin nehmen müssen.
Und dann hat man aber gemerkt, dass das nicht reicht.
Und jetzt muss ich in Solinen spritzen.
Seit wann nehmen Sie, ich verstehe das nicht.
Seit sechs Wochen.
Und das habe ich heute Morgen auch genommen, ich habe ganz bald meine Medikamente genommen.
Aber vor einem Jahr, Diabetes mellitus wurde festgestellt.
Ja, so ungefähr vor einem Jahr.
Und die erste Zeit habe ich eben nur mit Formin genommen.
Und dann hat man gemerkt, dass das nicht ausreicht.
Momentan nehmen Sie mit Formin ein?
Nein, in Solinen.
Nur in Solinen, okay.
Und gibt es noch etwas als Vorerkrankungen?
Na ja, also man hat festgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen erhöhte Blutverzweite habe.
Okay, wurde hier Sie schon mal operiert?
Nee, sofern ich mich erinnern kann.
Ich glaube nicht mal in der Kindheit.
Nee, ich bin noch ganz komplett.
Okay.
Und Herrn Huber, sind Sie vollständig geimpft, auch gegen Corona, auch gegen Kinderheiz, Krankheit?
Gegen Kinder, gegen Kinderkrankheit ist das schon alles eine Weile her.
Aber ich denke, also gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft.
Aber was da noch so alles an Sachen ist, ich glaube aber,
dass ich gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten ausreicht.
Okay, gut.
Herr Huber, ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Na ja, das Einzige, was ich sicher weiß, dass ich so kein braunes Schlaster vertragen kann.
Da kriege ich sofort so rote Pünktchen auf der Haut.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Huber, rauchen Sie.
Ja, ich rauch eigentlich fast nicht mehr, nur noch so 5, 6 Zigaretten am Tag.
Früher habe ich mal viel, viel mehr geraucht.
Und damals, wie viele Zigarette haben Sie geraucht?
Täglich und seit, wie lange?
Also ich habe angefangen, richtig mitrauchen, als ich 20 war.
Und dann habe ich 40 Jahre lang so 15 Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Das Päckchen hat immer ein bisschen länger als ein Tag gedauert.
Und jetzt rauch ich nur noch so, ja, es langt so ein Päckchen, 4 Tage hin, also 5, 6 Zigaretten am Tag.
Ein Schilder guckt, Herr Huber, seit wann haben Sie 5 bis 6 Zigarette rauchen?
Ja, also eigentlich jetzt so seit 3 Jahren, würde ich sagen.
3 Jahre, okay.
Okay, Herr Huber, ich muss diese Fragen nicht stellen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen.
Ich trinke ein, zwei Schlächer Bier am Tag, ja.
Täglich.
Ja, ziemlich regelmäßig, ja.
Okay.
Eine Routine Frage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich,
haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, mit Drogen habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Okay.
Herr Huber, wir sind fast fertig.
Ich möchte nur eine Frage über Ihre Familie geschickt und Ihre soziale Leven stellen.
Leven Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also mein Vater, der ist im Alter von 85 gestorben, der hatte Blasenkrebs.
Meine Mutter lebt allerdings noch, hoch betarnt, ja.
Die ist in einer Pflegeeinrichtung untergebracht.
Die ist halt schon sehr, sehr alt.
Aktuell ist sie aber im Krankenhaus, weil sie so ein Geschwür vom Liegen hat am Rücken.
Das muss jetzt ein bisschen ausführlicher behandelt werden im Krankenhaus.
Sie meinen Druckgeschwür?
Ja, so ein Druckgeschwür hat sie am Druckgeschwür.
Momentan, Sie ist in Krankenhaus.
Genau, ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister, ich war alleine.
Ja, Herr Huber, ich beinmute Sie sind momentan Rentner.
Ja, ich bin in der Alltagszeit.
Also ich muss noch so ein bisschen arbeiten, aber nicht so viel.
Ich muss nur noch beschränkte Stundenzahl arbeiten.
Und ich bin angestellt bei der Stadt beim Sozialamt.
Herr Huber, Sie sind verheiratet?
Ich bin verwitwit.
Okay.
Leben Sie allein?
Ja, ich nehme alleine.
Kinder sind alle aus dem Haus.
Wir haben drei Kinder, aber die sind jetzt schon alle groß.
Sie wohnen alle nicht mehr hier.
Okay, und ich hoffe, Sie sind gesund?
So viel ich weiß, sind die alle gesund?
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Okay, Herr Huber, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder Fragen?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich glaube ich alles wichtige gesagt.
Jetzt möchte ich natürlich noch wissen, wie das sein kann,
dass das mit einmal einem so schlecht ist.
Und ja, so etwas möchte ich natürlich auch nicht wieder erleben.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Aber ich kann momentan nicht mehr sagen,
ich muss ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen führen.
Diese Beschwerden haben viele Ursache.
Deswegen muss erst mal Sie körperlich untersuchen
und danach ein Blut abnehmen.
Und ja, gegen ebenfalls eine Computer-Tomografie durchführen.
Was ist das für eine Untersuchung?
Eine Computer-Tomografie?
Ja, Computer-Tomografie ist eine moderne Bildgewandesverfahren.
Schmerzlos und aber hat Rahlen.
Aber wir können die Organe gut beurteilen,
mit diesem Matrimonial.
Was wollen Sie denn da untersuchen?
Erstens möchte ich kontrollieren,
ob es eine Blutung sein könnte.
Das ist so niedrig, aber ich möchte kontrollieren.
Und gegen ebenfalls eine MRT,
kann eine Kernspiel-Tomografie durchführen.
Es hilft uns bei Beurteilung weich gewöhnliche Gehirn.
Also Sie meinen, ich habe etwas im Kopf?
Im Gotteswillen kriege ich richtig Angst?
Machen Sie keine Sorge, Sie sind momentan gute Händen.
Wir haben eine große Team hier
und wir haben alle Geräte für Sie.
Dann hoffe ich, dass es nicht so schlimm wird.
Wenn Sie einen Blatt lassen, lasse ich Euro5.
Ja, wunderbar.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen eine andere Frage?
Hallo Herr Huber, hatten Sie schon dieselbe Bechwärte?
Fre? Oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
So etwas ist mit zum ersten Mal passiert.
Deswegen bin ich auch so erschrocken,
weil ich das überhaupt nicht kenne.
Danke schön.
Guten Abend Herr Huber.
Sie bekommen seit sechs Wochen in Zürich ein Bitte.
Aber in diesem Zeitraum haben Sie Untersuchten
von Hausarzt oder Ihre Blutwerte schon,
wurde kontrolliert.
Einmal nach zwei Wochen ist das untersucht worden,
aber jetzt in den letzten Tagen nicht.
Sie haben schon gesagt, das erste Episode,
aber hatten Sie schon wegen dieser Insulinschipritze
Nebun-Effekt, Nebun-Wirkungen?
Ich habe das letzte nicht ganz richtig verstanden.
Wegen dieser Insulinschipritze hatten Sie ähnliche Bechwärten?
Ach so, das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen,
dass die Insulinschipritze so etwas macht.
Nein, habe ich noch nicht gemerkt.
Wenn Sie als die Trauben, die Sie angenommen haben,
nicht die Bechwärten besser geworden, oder?
Dann ist mir mit einmal ein bisschen besser geworden,
sonst hätte ich das jetzt auch gar nicht hier so aushalten können.
Danke schön.
Herr Huber, haben Sie am Morgen Ihre Insulinschipritze?
Ja, habe ich gesagt, ich habe meine Tabletten und meine Medikamente so genommen wie immer.
Herr Huber, während der Unfall, hätten Sie einen Kalter in Schweiz bemerkt?
Keine Unfall.
Also, ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Ich habe nur gemerkt, dass mir schlecht war.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich so einen Schweißausbruch hatte.
Herr Huber, haben Sie auch irgendwann in Ihrem Körper Zuckungen?
Zuckungen habe ich nicht.
Aber es gibt Zittern.
Hände zittern, ja.
Also, Hände kribbeln und ich war ein bisschen zittrig.
Herr Huber, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie heute Morgen
wenig gegessen haben wegen der Zeit.
Ja, ich habe verschlafen und die Freunde haben gewartet mit den Parlen an.
Okay, aber haben Sie gleiche Menge Insulinschipritze?
Ich wusste ja nicht, wie lange ich wenig Zeit habe.
Mit einem Standen, die vor der Tür standen, und dann hatte ich noch nicht viel gegessen.
Ja, aber meine Frage, Sie haben nicht so viel gegessen,
aber Sie haben gleiche Menge Insulinchipritze gemacht.
Wie man mir das gesagt hat, habe ich das Insulin gesammelt.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt, frage ich.
Können wir Arsatz-Gesipre anfangen?
Können wir auch so machen?
Erst mal ein bisschen, ich habe versucht Arsatz-Gesipre,
aber nur am Anfang.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, ich versuche nur, nur den Beruf.
Ja, wollen wir erst den Kollegen lassen und dann Sie?
Nein, erst mal ich.
Sie wollen erst?
Ja, und dann meine Kollegen.
Aber kurs, kurs.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen heute Morgen während der körpärliche Belastung
akut aufgetretener Pyrsinkopersymptomatik vorgestellt.
Gut.
Obwohl der Patient ein Insulin-Apengiger-Patient ist,
treten diese Symptome auf, nachdem er nach einem kleinen Früchte
mit dem Radfahrenbegonen hatte.
Verkügt die Patientin, die die Patientin folgen,
und die Begleitsymptome aufgefahren,
verkügt die Palpitation,
erestet die beiden Hände und Tremor,
Schweißausprüche,
befürchtet, dass sie einstürmen.
Nein, er hat nur gesagt, er hat Sehstörung gehabt.
Aufgesiltenaftfragen besteht keine Barnehmungstürung
Fibersinkope, Anginepectus oder ein Engelgefühl in der Brust.
Besteht nicht.
Gut.
Jetzt sind die Messlatten hochgelegt.
Jetzt kommt Ihre Version.
Wir fangen erst mal klein an.
Amit, bitte schön.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarztin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen,
haben Sie dafür geflogen?
Ja, klar. Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Richard Huber, 63-jährige Patient,
er kam heute wegen akut aufgetretener Schlechtgefühl,
die alle Beschwerden bei Fahrradfahren treten.
Laut des Patienten hat er heute Morgen wenig gegessen,
obwohl er ins Sulin schiebt.
Er ist bekannter Diabetiker?
Ja, genau.
Annamnes ist unaufwähig, bis auf vertigo.
Wichtig zu erwähnen ist, dass ein Traubensucker,
der Patient, besser geworden ist.
Moment.
Er ist nach Einnahme eines Traubensuckerstücks,
das Befinden des Patienten sich verbessert hat.
Ja.
Er leidet seit einem Jahr Diabetes mellitus
und Hyperlipidemia.
Ich habe vergessen zu fragen,
welche Typen in Sulin und wie viel in welchem Dosierung er nutzt.
Ich frage bei Untersuchung.
Vielleicht hat er ja auch ein Zettel dabei.
Ja.
Sonst hat er Brown-Pflaster Allergie.
Er raucht seit 3 Jahren 5 bis 6 Zigaretten täglich.
Früher hat er 15 Zigarrette täglich 40 Jahre lang geraucht.
Er trinkt ein Fleisch biatäglich.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er ist Angestellter, verwidert, lebt allein, hat gesunde 3 Kinder.
3 gesunde Kinder?
3 gesunde Kinder.
Sein Vater ist an einer Süßeskrebs gestorben.
Er hat eine Belastung.
Er ist falsch.
Alles richtig.
Ich überlege gerade, wie das Lateinisch heißt.
Seine Mutter ist...
Armblasenkratzinum.
Dein Mutter ist in Krankenhaus wegen...
Ich habe nicht erinnern.
Druckgeschwur.
Wie nennen wir das noch?
Entschuldigung.
Ja, dekondition.
Sie ist in einem Pflegeheim.
Sie hat ein Dekuditus am Rücken entwickelt.
Sie wird gerade im Krankenhaus behandelt.
Gut.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Mein Verdachtdiagnose ist Hypoglycemie.
Als Differenzialdiagnose ist es eine Diagnose.
Ich denke, die Gehirnblutung...
Ich werde meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Ich werde körperliche Untersuchungen.
Besonders achte ich neurologische Untersuchungen.
Ich nehme den Patienten Blut ab.
Ich kontrolliere Blutzucker.
Ich werde eine MRT durchführen.
Was ist Ihre Frage?
Ich leite eine Gehirnblutung.
Besonderheiten, Aufhältigkeit, Neubildung, Blutung im Kopf.
Ich habe vergessen zu sagen, dass der Patient sehr stolz ist.
Dann würde ich sagen, gucken Sie nach den Patienten.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Lausenden, wie es Ihnen geht.
Was sind die Ergebnisse der Untersuchung?
Das ist kein komplizierter Fall.
Es liegt auf der Hand.
Das ändert nichts daran, dass man auch sprachlich Probleme haben kann.
Das ist etwas, das relativ häufig kommt.
Welche Probleme?
Ein Problem, das immer wieder beim braunen Pflaster aufkommt.
Alle sagen immer, er hat ein braunes Pflasterallergie.
Das klingt nicht so gut.
Er reagiert allergisch auf braunes Pflaster.
Machen Sie sich die Mühe, den Satz zu sagen.
Eine braune Pflasterallergie.
Es klingt so, als ob die allergiebraun ist.
Man kann auf andere braune Sachen allergisch sein.
Aber eine Pflasterallergie auf braunes Pflaster.
Dann haben Sie eine Wortschöpfung gemacht.
Er hat ein schlecht gefühlt.
Das muss man ein bisschen anders beschreiben.
Er hat sich plötzlich schlecht gefühlt.
Man kann sagen.
Es gibt noch jede Menge lateinische Bezeichnungen.
Wie sagen wir denn noch?
Die Presse in den Kopf ist eine gute Idee.
Aber ich kann es nicht verwenden.
Noch mal, bitte.
Eine Presse in den Kopf.
Das ist ein schöner Begriff, der dieses Spektrum gut beschreibt.
Aber schlecht gefühlt tut es einfach nicht.
Weil er plötzlich Übelkeit bemerkt hat.
Er hat sich schlecht gefühlt.
Er hatte See störung.
Er fühlte sich etwas benommen und hat geschwitzt.
Das haben Sie alle beschrieben.
Das waren die Hauptsachen, die mir aufgefallen sind.
Sie haben nicht nach der Insulin-Dosis gefaucht.
Nach der Art des Insulins wäre es wahrscheinlich etwas,
das der Patient hätte angeben können.
Wie ich die Lage einschätze.
Aber natürlich liegt es auf der Hand,
dass dieses Zusammentreffen von Insulin wenig zu viel verwendet wird.
Insulin hat wenig gefrühstückkörperliche Anstrengung.
Das hat das zu dieser Attacke geführt.
Was würde man, nachdem es dem Patienten besser geht,
auf alle Fälle mit den Patienten machen?
Abgesehen von den rein medizinischen Maßnahmen.
Was braucht er?
Er braucht mehr Info über seine Krankheit.
Es gibt diese Diabetes-Schulungen.
Offensichtlich hat er nicht richtig aufgepasst.
Sonst wäre ihm diese Geschichte vermutlich nicht passiert.
Dann hätte er gesagt, liebe Leute, ihr müsst noch auf mich warten.
Ich habe mein Insulin gespritzt.
Ich muss noch etwas essen.
Er hätte vielleicht gemerkt, ich bin knapp mit der Zeit.
Ich kann nicht so gut frühstücken.
Ich spritze ein bisschen weniger.
Aber er hat nicht gemacht.
Er hat ihn aus der Bahn geworfen.
Ich denke, das zeigt,
dass der Patient nicht so gut Bescheid weiß über seine Erkrankung.
Oder dass viele ungewöhnliche Sachen zusammengekommen sind.
Gut.
Abgesehen von der sprachlichen Neu-Schöpfung,
fand ich das sprachlich, aber eigentlich auch sehr gut.
Sie machen ein paar Fehler.
Irgendwas hat aufgetreten bei ihnen.
Es ist egal.
Es ist aufgetreten.
Sonst war das sprachlich sehr okay.
Sie haben konsequent ihre Fragen an den Patienten gemacht.
Ich fand es gut, dass sie das nicht in der Wiedergabe haben.
Sie haben vorher unterbrochen und gesagt,
wir gucken, wie es ihnen geht.
Wir messen den Blutzucker.
Damit wir gucken, ob alles so weit stabil ist.
Das ist sicherlich ein wichtiger Punkt.
Sie hätten gerne noch an den Arzt weitergeben können.
Ich habe inzwischen Blutzucker-Wert überprüft.
Der war jetzt, was ich im unteren Normbereich.
Oder jedenfalls nicht mehr so kritisch.
Blutdruck und EKG waren in Ordnung.
Das hätte man noch machen können.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Sass wieder schicken?
Ich möchte diese Untersuchung einrichten.
Sie fragen mich schwierige Sachen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich eben gesagt habe.
Er hat die Untersuchung unterbrochen.
Das muss er jetzt machen.
Ich habe die Untersuchung unterbrochen.
Um die Vitalparameter zu überprüfen.
Insbesondere im Blutzuckertest zu machen.
Das könnte man sagen.
Entschuldigung, gab es falsche Struktur?
Nein.
Sie haben das gar nicht gesagt.
Wir machen eine Unterbrechung.
Ich untersuche sie.
Sie haben das hinterher dem Kollegen nicht gesagt.
Sie haben nicht gesagt,
als klar war, wie die Situation ist,
habe ich erst mal nicht weitergefragt.
Ich habe den Patienten grob orientierend untersucht.
Ich habe insbesondere Blutzucker und Blutdruck bestimmt.
Das wäre gut, wenn der Oberarzt weiß,
dass sie das schon gemacht haben.
Sie haben damit auch ihre Sorgfalspflicht nachgekommen.
Darum geht es.
Sie haben das richtig gemacht.
Das ist der Punkt.
Gut.